[Music]
hi I'm Danny ran and I went a long time
let's go you know here I'm Danny Rand
welcome
I left here ten years old and a jet my
parents I became the lone survivor Danny
Rand
back from the dead why didn't waited
this long to show up
how the hell did he learn martial arts
ready train come on
my father instilled in me a love and
respect for this company that has never
fade this is my home the brand is my
company the city is no place for daddy
we will give it up no covenant will many
what happened to you why are you really
back here some bad people got on the
inside criminals I know what they are
but they can do it despite them we need
someone with special skills I've been
training my whole life
[Music]
I'm going with you
no you're not
you need me
the change is coming down become what
you were meant to be I am the iron hand
how does that mean
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so everyone's
going crazy about iron fist let's break
this down
most of this is going to be about the
iron fist trailer what's going on during
the series but I also address crossover
with Luke age Heroes for Hire
in the classic comic book costume in the
other Netflix series like defenders in
Punisher which are also dropping this
year so there is a new round of the
marvel giveaway I'm giving away one of
those spider-man figures all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video I totally like
Claire temples introduction to this
she's kind of like the explainer
character Danny ran says I'm the iron
fist - like what what the hell's that
supposed to mean so you have like a lot
of people that will be watching this -
have no idea what's going on with iron
fist from the comics so this trailer
just spells it out a little bit more
clearly Danny ran comes back after a
plane crash when he was a young boy he
grew up in Conlan the sort of inner
dimensional city I don't know how
they're going to change that for the TV
show but the way they explained his
powers from the TV show is just in the
harnessing of his Chi that's what you're
seeing when you see his fists glow so
they're not on fire like they are in the
comics and in the comics he got some of
those powers when he plunged his fist
into the heart of a dragon so the song
that they play in the trailer is a bit
of a wink at that it's a posh haze I'm a
dragon so this is meant to be a very
real world Iron Fist it's not exactly
like the comics there's always minor
changes so for instance you have the
Meechum children in Danny Rand standing
here is he's come back to society look
I'm not dead this is partly my company I
inherited my father's shares so now I'm
co-owner with the Meacham's and they
give off this really sinister vibe but
he used to be very good friends with joy
Meacham here so you see they have like
special connections throughout the
trailer the other Meechum Ward Meechum
doesn't like him so much you kind of get
that vibe it's pretty clear from the way
they present them in the trailer the
kingpin level big bad though is Herald
Meechum Danny rands father's former
business partner who was responsible for
the plane crash he orchestrated that so
that he could take over the company
so when Danny Rand is talking about the
hand infiltrating his company like you
see Harald Meechum looking at the
imprint of the hand here he's talking to
crane mother Rand enterprises is very
tied up with the
and they're helping import things you
see these shipping containers with
Meechum on the side this is sort of a
callback to daredevil season 2 when the
hand was trying to import black sky so
that they could raise the demon that
they're worshipping so now that's sort
of an Electra storyline but that's very
daredevil centric so now you're getting
some crossover with iron fist
so his company is sort of the
infrastructure that the hand is using to
accomplish their goals the other villain
you see him fighting here this is sort
of like the small bat is Luo Cheng in
the comics he serves as the host for
this demon that's trying to get at Iron
Fist power the source of his power is
the dragon so I don't know how they're
going to incorporate the actual dragon
the source of Iron Fist power into this
it seems like they toned that down a
little bit so maybe he just knows how to
harness his Chi the same way that Iron
Fist does so Xue Cheng works with crane
mother who's working with the hand who
is using Herald Meechum to import all of
their resources
you probably recognize Jessica Hedwig as
Colleen winch is kicking a whole lot of
ass at the end of Luke Cage Claire
temple pulls that little tab off the
martial arts lessons bulletin that's for
colleen wings classes so she teaches
self-defense but she's also this ally of
iron fist in the comics she doesn't have
quite the mystical origins that he does
but her family descends from a line of
badasses
so all this craziness is in her blood
and she does know how to harness your
Chi in the same way that Iron Fist does
but she's not quite as powerful so
that's probably why you don't see her
fists glowing like his but a lot of the
scenes in the trailer here stuff that
they showed off at Comic Con him walking
in the funny scene of him getting carted
out by the security guards just taking
them down like it's nobody's business
the Iron Fist version of the daredevil
hallway fight that all the Netflix
series of God Luke Cage got his version
of that iron fist is going to have his
then showing off a little bit about the
magnitude of his power you can see they
toned it down a little bit he's crazy
powerful in the comics but remember
these are supposed to be street-level
heroes so they toned it down just a
little bit so I would say he's about as
powerful maybe a little bit more
powerful than Power Man when he's at
full strength Luke Cage is the strongest
the most indestructible but Iron Fist
hits the hardest they could probably go
toe-to-toe but as we learn from Jessica
Jones you
actually hurt Luke Cage it's just his
skin that's unbreakable not his internal
organs so it'll be fun to see that meet
up on-screen during defenders misty
night is supposed to have a cameo but
like I said the love interest in this is
going to be calling wing so in the way
that the Luke Cage series changed a
little bit about that in the comics
misty Knight and Luke Cage weren't
really a thing in the comics but they
changed that for the TV show they're
also changing iron fists just a little
bit but that might change when we get to
defender the music is going to feel very
much like Luke Cage so maybe a lot more
wu-tang they called Luke Cage the
wu-tang off' ocation of the Marvel
Universe the really big thing about iron
fist though is that he is the only
person on the defenders that understands
the true threat that the hand poses
daredevil has learned a little bit about
it from stick but Iron Fist has spent
way more time in Kunlun learning about
the mystical war between the chased in
the hand so he's the guy to come in and
say look there are a lot of problems in
Harlem all over New York City but
there's this even bigger problem in the
secret organization in this mystical war
that we need to stop a lot of you are
asking me if Danny Rand will get his
comic book costume in the way that
daredevil got a costume Luke Cage even
wore the yellow shirt for a little while
I think that there will definitely be a
version of the costume people about thin
John's he's come out and said look
marvel will kill me and he just kind of
jumped around a little bit so I think
that just confirms there will be a
version of the comic book costume but it
probably won't happen till the very end
of the series but like the trailer says
everything is dropping on March 17th
that's a Friday of course I'll be doing
episodes for it leave all your requests
for bonus videos in the comments below
there's going to be a bunch of Iron Fist
defender stuff because defenders is
coming this summer and then the Punisher
series is supposed to drop at the end of
the year so there will be three new
Netflix series dropping this year it is
going to be hard core while you wait for
that next video you can click here to
rewatch all the Super Bowl trailers and
you can click here to learn about the
different colors of lightening on the
flash thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
in the next video
you